happy tuesday reject nation greg and
john here we got ourselves another
trailer for
the snyder cut now here it's pretty much
the same trailer in terms of footage
but i hear there's some new shots
sprinkled throughout i know the other
trailer pretty damn well
so let's see if i can spot every new
image
or updated look that they got throughout
this trailer it'll be fun to see also
because of the
music issue that they ran into we're
gonna keep the audio pretty low
just to be safe and considering that
there's no dialogue throughout it
doesn't really matter does it and lastly
i did want to mention that on sunday i'm
going to be putting up a special
announcement video it's not
snyder cut related but it's something
that if you've been a subscriber of this
channel for a while i really hope you do
go check out it's something very special
so keep a lookout for that on sunday i
mentioned that a few times throughout
the week anywho let's finally watch this
now i've heard there was a secret code
that david played and it pleased the
lord
the fourth the fifth
hey that's a new shot
you got some wonder woman and aquaman
there
new shot oh
i miss football
[Laughter]
love that shot of him doing
[Music]
trailer either
[Music]
i've seen this so many times i mean not
this one
but
one the song just swells
your emotions
few new shots in there let me point them
out
take us through eclipse notes scrolling
through this i only spotted like a
couple of new
shots for sure that image that they had
before
it was it was just as close up here of
ben affleck looking at it
and now you see superman jumping up
doing superman pose and victor stone
looking at kids playing football
remembering the times when he used to
play football
dark side i feel like this is probably
the most glorified new shot of the
trailer yes
poses just sci-fi chaos and suits his
followers are behind him going yeah we
did it
we did it we dark sided this this
close-up on the batmobile
going to town here shooting up some pair
of demons before cutting into the
hippolyta shot
whereas before it just transitioned to
the hippolyta shot i watched that
interview that grace randolph did
with zach the her most recent one he did
say that there's only going to be about
four to five new minutes
shot for this movie like new scenes some
of that being
jared leto's joker from the way he
talked about it he didn't go into
specifics we teased like an
apocalyptic take on him yeah like some
weird embattled like feral jokers
yeah which sounds pretty cool
to me to actually see some type of joker
like that
yeah to see him build off of what that
character or what that iteration of the
character was
already into something more apocalyptic
like almost seems like you're headed
right toward like some mad max joker of
sorts which
yeah i mean i could i i'm definitely
curious about that
we'll see how this turns out and uh i'm
excited for it man
uh it's gonna be a sweet four hours
let's see how it goes can't wait for the
snyder cup guys
what do you think of these five new
images that we got
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell keep a lookout for
that special video i got coming up